a reject nation it's Greg Alva here it
is midnight we've been covering a lot
for e3 have a lot more shot that we were
planning on uploading today today being
Wednesday and try to fit in the Nunn
trailer and all that already tampering
enough with the way YouTube's algorithm
works with the countless uploads we've
been doing to get the e3 stuff shot and
edited but the Dumbo teaser trailer
dropped so you got to just rearrange the
whole schedule for that because this is
Dumbo and it's Disney and this is a
beloved classic that's getting a
live-action adaptation and I had no idea
it was apparently this is directed by
Tim Burton it stars Tim Burton's new
Helena bonham-carter Eva Green Colin
Farrell and Michael Keaton and I'm
mainly gonna tune in for the actors and
nothing for the elephant I'm here by
myself today cuz Jon's celebrating his
birthday with his family thanks for the
invite John said I'll shoot this by
myself yeah alright Tim Burton don't
disappoint me again
[Music]
haha
[Music]
look at that we're all family here no
matter how small this does look
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
Danny DeVito
Wow
that looks incredibly sweet so cute okay
I gotta say you know when you hear Tim
Burton the first thing you start to
think of is a lot of crazy visuals and
CGI fest these days well there's some
CGI in here it's nice to see Tim Burton
going back to something that feels a lot
more grounded
the production design on this thing
looks really great it looks like there's
a lot of practical effects Dumbo looks
practical at night it's not practical
and I know in the Dumbo cartoon you know
you got a bunch of other animals in
there as well I think it's really smart
that for the teaser trailer you keep
this very grounded it's just about the
human beings that are taking care of
Dumbo it's just Dumbo centric the entire
time you know if it's Dumbo movie which
had some very popular Disney classic
musical numbers they hint at some stuff
where they're in the circus and that use
looks like they're putting on some type
of stage performance so I imagine
there'll be some musical numbers in here
hopefully you do get that because I
think if you're gonna do a live-action
Dumbo you're gonna want that with Tim
Burton taking on this material I don't
know if he's gonna decide if Disney will
let him just have a lot more creative
freedom with how much he wants to change
from the source material I don't know if
the Dumbo cartoon is based off of
something else when Disney does a
live-action adaptation this horse
material will be there cartoon and I
don't know how much difference is he's
gonna actually have with it big part of
Dumbo's journey was how he was bullied
by a bunch of the other animals and
they're in like I said you don't really
see any other animals in here but you
know there's some obvious homage is to
the cartoon at 108 you do see that
really cool image is famous in the
cartoon with the bubble Dumbo and I
think that sequence is from the pink
elephants on parade musical number I
think with Tim Burton doing that
sequence I think that could be something
very cool if we go all Tim Burton out on
it I mean and you got point out as a Tim
Burton fan you got two big actors from
Tim Burton films coming back you got
Danny DeVito who was penguin and Batman
Returns
I think he's not other things a Tim
Burton but more importantly you got
Beetlejuice and Batman himself Michael
Keaton in these trailers oh come on
that's some pretty awesome stuff what I
liked about the caesars it showed a lot
of tone it showed a lot of its heart
this feels like it's gonna be an
emotional piece and I feel like Tim
Burton and week
away a lot with his crazy visuals
they're not really that captivating
anymore this seems a lot more grounded
more territory that we've been wanting
Tim Burton to go back to and it seems to
be a lot about its heart and its drama
this is more of the Tim Burton fantasy
world I would like him to be in I'm
actually looking forward to this this
was pretty cool all right well you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bail subscribe buttons
are practically broken these days and
you can check us on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A s music
video coverage would love to have you
become a patron eject today